Brian thank you
um uh I think it's it's worthwhile us
getting going I understand um it's a
long day I know that I would hope out of
this meeting there is then a positive
motion to take forward to the council
which I understand is meeting it
at four o'clock this afternoon so our
duty this morning is very much to
fulfill
the penultimate step in our annual
accountability
responsibilities to the community which
is to buy which is to
um
uh recommended to counsel the adoption
of the annual report on which we also
know we have an opinion that will be
given as included in your agenda packs
so
um it's uh it's great to be here and I
just would like to acknowledge
we have Derek Olsen our board up
director here
Derek I'd suspect probably for you and
Stephen it would be well useful if you
came to the table I suspect you're going
to be part of the process as well and we
also had Stephen Walker who is the
executive director of audit New Zealand
and I'm deeply appreciative also that
Stephen is here today as well so can I
invite you to the front here you might
as well come up as part of the meeting
as well
um I'm a big impression of the week is
here today for it's an important day in
terms of the annual report
uh so look fishy any apologies
um we look like we've got a full muscle
thanks Mr chair I need to apologize for
an early departure I have a pre-arranged
legal case that I need to attend what
time do you need 10 15. I would hope
that we punished before then that's the
cheers that's the cheers because of this
to a meeting but uh I'm I would hope
that would be the case as well Leslie
but let's take a precautionary uh motion
that we acknowledge the early departure
of uh these sleeves any other properties
this time
thank you Darren oh for the motion alone
please say aye all right
I make an assumption but is there any is
there any matters of of your personal
interests that should be raised at the
stage for the matter that's in front of
us
presume there is none
that puts us straight into the only
agenda item on the paper which is which
is item three which is the annual report
adoption so the way I'd like to do this
is I'd like to invite Patricia
do it at least twice in the reading so
this is the first time Patricia is to
say thank you that you've got us here as
we all discuss I suspect it's been a
reasonable challenge to get here and
Patricia
shouldered the effort and I just want to
make certain that before we get to front
of me that I acknowledge that Patricia
so thank you so I'd like Patricia to
talk to her paper and lead us through
what are the key decisions I'd like to
then invite Derek as our auditor
director to talk to us also about the
paper and then I will open it up for
questions and comments by
the committee and then we can move to
the motion so Patricia thank you in
advance thank you Mr chair
so today is the this committee is we're
proposing a set of recommendations to go
through to council this afternoon to
adopt the annual report
we also want to adopt the draft summary
annual report audit New Zealand is still
working on the audit of that but for the
to make it as quick as possible give
delegation to the chair of this
committee as well as the acting GM's
finance and assurance and the chief
executive to sign that off once it's
complete legislatively we have to have
the summary out within 20 days of that
annual report being adopted so that just
speeds the process up you also have
within the agenda both the draft audit
opinion from from Derek and I'll let him
speak to that as well as the letter of
representation which we are required to
sign to give to audit New Zealand which
says that we've provided all the
information that they have asked for but
it does make those specific comments
which I'll come to later
so if I look at the key issues for this
annual report as Bruce has said it is
it's been a long time coming we are
nearly nine months into the financial
year
um the key issues that we had was the
revaluation of the assets being at
infrastructure assets as well as their
operational land and building
and this resulted in a 215 million
dollar increase in the value of those
assets as a result of the revaluation
all those revaluations with the
exception of roading and library books
were undertaken by independent valuers
in relation to roading we used our own
staff valued our roads Bridges and
footpaths and then we had that peer
reviewed by an independent valuer so
you've got some assurance that those
numbers as large as they are
do have some independent basis
library books we never we don't it's
immaterial compared to our other assets
to get that peer-reviewed
that increase is similar to what we've
been seeing around the country with the
increase in the construction price
indexes but also the cost of that some
are seeing by reply in the replacement
of assets
it is their policy to actually revalue
every three years so as many of you will
recall last year we ended up with a
qualification on our asset values
because we chose not to revalue early we
didn't believe that at 30 June we had
that the indices were indicating a
significant increase in the value so we
chose not to do it and we risk keep a
reevaluation cycle at three years
so we this is not an unusual increase to
see
other than um
that we've still had this we have
reported many times to the council we
did have an operating Surplus
um of 6.6 million and that's an increase
of 2.2 million on the previous year
um the group after tax was on par had a
5.1 million
um Surplus which was on par with last
year
and we now have Council has total assets
of 1.3 billion dollars
predominantly those are sitting in our
infrastructure assets but it's a large
number
um
and they're borrowings as I've said many
times 102.1 million at 30 June and
that's the equivalent of three thousand
eight hundred and three dollars per
property within the city boundary and
that has actually increased
from last year as we start taking on
more debt for our Capital program
in terms of their level of service
achievement
Council achieved 64 of the measures now
these measures are slightly different to
what was said in the 21 annual report
because this is the first year of the
ltp that we're reporting on
and that's probably where I'll leave it
the biggest issues there are some of the
two issues in regards to the letter of
representation they want to draw your
attention to isn't to re in regards to a
couple of technical points that we had
to do in relation to ICL
and that is I'm considering whether the
loan which Council has with ICL was
impaired at 30 June and whether we
needed to take a credit impairment our
conclusion was that we didn't
and the other is in relation to the
Consolidated group
and how ICL as an associate of ichl gets
fed through and we have a Divergence in
accounting treatment between those two
um because ichl prepares its financial
statements as on a for-profit accounting
standard basis councils and a public
sector basis and there's a Divergence
about how we can treat those assets
which has resulted in a slightly
different outcome
but not a materially different outcome
so we have no impairment of the
associate
um at the council level
very it's technical but it is if someone
was looking at it would be very would
Spot It
I'll ask Derek if you want to go through
the opinion
yeah
thank you Patricia as Patricia has
indicated to intend to issue and accept
for audit opinion that will be included
in the annual for adoption today
um also as she has indicated we have
qualification relates to the
comparatives whereby we issued a
qualified opinion in last year's audit
report that relates to the property
plant and Equipment valuation and the
qualification this year relates to that
comparative figure as well as the
movement in the current year due to the
scope limitation on the closing balance
of the prior year
without modifying our opinion further we
have also included an emphasis of
massive paragraph relating to the three
order reforms that's currently happening
within within the environment
also to note some other significant
methods and issues and risks that we
dealt with during the audit as Patricia
has already highlighted one of the key
risks and significant risks for us was
the valuation process and it took this
year whereby Council revalued its
infrastructure assets mainly eroding and
the waters and as she said there was a
uplift of 250 million with regards to
your infrastructure assets
which is quite substantial
um and this was driven mainly by the
uplifting housing prices and land prices
of the past two years as well as the New
Zealand construction cost inflation
that resulted from macroeconomic
challenges including supply chain
challenges and Global Market disruptions
we looked at all the independent
evaluations that were performed as well
as peer reviews and we were satisfied
with the satisfied with the underlying
data and the reasonable reasonableness
of assumptions and lying the valuation
methodology
we also gained reasonable assurance that
the valuations complied with the
appropriate accounting standards and
valuation standards we also obtained
representations from the respective
valuers as internal as well as external
regarding the suitability for inclusion
of these values in the annual report
um Council also carries some of the
assets at cost and we assess these for
impairment but no impayment were
reflected on on those assets carried at
cost
another area a significant risk that we
identified for this year's audit as per
our order plan was around investment
property again you carry around 26
million worth of
investment properties on your balance
sheet and again assessing the investment
properties where we're satisfied that it
was carried at appropriate values within
the within the annual report but we have
made some minor recommendations to
council with regards to the asset
register containing your investment
property
also as always we do look at management
override of internal controls and
classify this as a significant risk in
all our audits
um as management is in a precarious
position whereby that can override
controls that can lead to fraud and
resulting in misstatement of the
financial statements again through our
order procedures effectively looking at
journals and any unusual transactions we
were satisfied that nothing came to our
attention that led us to believe that
there is any management override of
internal controls
also maybe two other issues to note we
did identify a material prior period
error this year
again this relates to invercargill city
property limited whereby the loan had to
be restated
now again without getting into the
technical jargon we just determined that
the loan had to be reclassified from
being
rather than being carried at a fair
value through profit and loss and this
is based on the conditions and terms of
the loan whereby in terms of the
accounting standards you need to do
certain tests we call it the svpi test
um
the solid payments for principle and
interest test
and we deemed that because of the
arrangement within the loan does not
meet the criteria as per this test it
had to be reclassified and that then
resulted in a prime period era
misstatement
and that was corrected easy as well
again as Patricia mentioned the two
items that's also included in our
representation letter I just want to
highlight that as well so that relates
to the invercargill central limited
share valuation
and as you reflected at a council level
uh the transaction is Unwound
meaning that you can reflect the value
of that investment at its value as as
per the
um independent valuation performed
but then
um at an ichl level that was impaired
based on the valuation that we received
from an independent value
we also needed to get our own expert
looking at that valuation uh seeing that
it was impaired
and just needing to assess the
assumptions and reasonableness of the
valuation
and effectively concluding that the
investment in ichl seeing that it's on a
for-profit Accounting Standards needed
to be impaired
relating to that as well is the possible
impairment of the loan whereby I see um
we buy Council Advanced 12.8 million to
ICL and again through our audit testing
and engaging with technical redeemed
that the loan is carried at fair value
but going forward uh Council might need
to reconsider and ensure that the credit
um the credit rating of the loan is is
appropriate
I think with that chair that's that's
all the issues that I want to highlight
from from our order thank you thank you
Derek and um I appreciate your comments
and yours Patricia so
um
members have responsibility is to do a
final
review of the accounts to consider the
letter of representation
and then as you can see there are a
suite of recommendations which
essentially
um is is at this stage and I haven't
stayed that way a positive
recommendation to council
that you adopt the annual report you
receive the ordered opinion
in the appropriate representations are
signed by the mayor and the chief
executive
and
um that will conclude
the the key part to our Academy
requirements for the 21 22 Financial
year just a couple of very brief
comments from me what is the value of
this information
um
and I'm going to put one quality one
qualitative statement here this
information is late
we knew it was late it should have been
done before Christmas
we covered that at our last risk
committee
and I want to acknowledge Stephen's
presence here
because as I indicated to you our
immediate need is to get the annual
report
adopted to do the work
but they're needed to be an accounting
and an accountability
order performance
so I'm grateful that both Derek and
Stephen are here because we planned at
the conclusion of this meeting
to start that accounting and
accountability for what we view as audit
performance
which has been expressed roundly as a
concern for this committee in the
service received by ICC
the value of having an audit is
important
while it can be difficult and sometimes
the annual report appears impenetrable
I want to reflect a couple of things
one
having an external
opinion on these financial statements
help us
have confidence we understand how our
financial strategy not anybody else's
how our financial strategy has worked
out in the course of the year
the second thing and clearly it's been a
key Focus
for both Derek and Patricia as the
accounts have been prepared it gives us
a sighter on our future costs
in the financial strategy you must be
considering in your annual report and
that clearly is the impact
of being substantial asset owner
and the challenges that we will have as
does the entire territorial local
Authority sector indeed probably
actually the regional sector as well
then maintaining its asset base and
levels of service so while it might
appear very quick and and hopefully it's
a quick process this morning that this
is a significant
piece of work by us in terms of
recommending to your colleagues this
afternoon that we see the audit through
to its conclusion so do I have uh
comments or questions properly first of
of Derek and um and Patricia and and
comments think Tom
thank you
um I don't have a financial background
um but I've shared a number of companies
in the private sector and I've got a you
know instinctive abundance of qualified
opinions and maybe I read more unto them
than I should
as I read this I really struggle you
understand why this opinion is qualified
when the
um the the last you know full external
valuation it was done presumably was
audited by it was 2019 the last one
and this one has been fully audited in
um 2022
um and there is a gap between them which
you presumably have audited and
recognized
um and yet the the qualified opinion
that's a consequence of the fact that we
decided that we would not do a full
valuation in 2021 which was actually not
required of us so could you maybe just
explain a little bit your thinking
behind deciding to make a qualified
opinion maybe I read more than either
than I should but I really don't like
qualified opinions
um so can you just explain why you felt
it necessary to do that
counselor through your cheat um so
um we did qualify last year's accounts
because uh
the accounting standards require Counsel
on an annual basis to determine whether
there's a material movement between the
carrying value of its assets and the
fair value of its assets so the value
they're carrying in their books compared
to what they would get in an open market
if they had to sell it
um when looking at the fair value
assessment that was performed by Council
there were indicators that did indicate
that there will be a material movement
and if there is a material movement the
standards then require you to do a full
valuation
uh Council opted not to do a full
valuation and as a result due to the
scope limitation placed on us not being
able to determine determine an accurate
value we had to qualify and issue and
express and accept for opinion on the
value of
property planting equipment for that
Financial year
now for the current year seeing that
there's uncertainty around the actual
value of that opening balance the
movement then this year to correct it as
we know the current year closing balance
is fairly reflected through our order
procedures
but the movement in the current year is
uncertain due to the uncertainty with
regards to the opening balance
means the that qualification still being
carried forward for this year
I can get vaccines thank you Gene thank
you Tom I think it's fair to say if I
can reflect on the work of the committee
the opinion for uh the prior year was
one that the committee did disagreed
with
but it's it's there it's um uh role and
right to express as independent view
the committee has considered
uh at the time that we had to adopt the
annual report for 2031 we recognized
that there would be an impact on this
opinion
um in the way that Derek's outlined so
we were aware of that while I would like
to
um
uh leave your nuns in terms two things
one we have four also got a fight
opinion two we disagree with the opinion
last year
it was a professional disagreement so
the chair I suppose my main surprise is
the fact that it's automatically carried
through this year rather than have been
extinguished by the fact that it was a
qualified opinion last year and a
difference I've been uh yes but as Derek
has said unfortunately in in the view of
the auditor it influences the opening
balance that we have in our balance
sheet and also the movements through our
profit loss sorry our statement of
income and expenditure for the course of
the year so it does have it it does you
know I get the the professional and
there I say the technical reasons why uh
from an independent auditor perspective
there's a setup will affect the opinion
this year
okay so I've got uh parangi thank you
thanks chair look my query your question
is around the valuations and obviously
everyone's heard about this um uh rise
and the cost of construction the the
cost of products and everything but my
understanding that it is a blip and um
and you get these uh every now and then
and it relates to obviously the low very
low interest rates but uh housing market
boom and and things like that now I I'd
imagine the value of our assets is
deemed by
not what we would sell it for but what
the cost of replacement would be so I
mean we have 30-year
infrastructure plans we have assets
that only require placing in 70 years
time now how do we
how do we put a a replacement value on
an asset that is not going to be touched
for such a long time but we know it has
to be done
and how do we work out an accentuated
valuation on a spur of the moment sort
of feeling for that asset when we know
that those
um half a billion dollars worth of
assets aren't going to be replaced for
20 odd years yet we're valuing them now
at some accentuated value
it doesn't make any sense to me or how
do you and so how does out of these
professional value is actually ration it
out
that the you could actually put that
value on that product right now write on
that asset right now so the the
valuations and the annual report mainly
on the infrastructure are done and what
we would call optimized depreciated
replacement costs so we look at if we've
got a hundred kilometers apart of a
certain diameter at a certain depth how
much it would cost to replace those
today
then we go well that part still has 70
years left in it so we discount it back
for how much has been used and we'd keep
doing that on a on a regular basis
however if we go actually it's only got
a couple of years left and it it gets
with a very low value so we're looking
at replacement cost but dropping it down
so we know
how much it would cost us to replace
today which is the eye watering sum but
actually as we replace them over their
life it doesn't really change the
infrastructure plans as we would
normally have them it just gives us a
snapshot each three years as into what
the value is looking like so how do we
how do we mitigate the this sort of
one-off extreme construction blip
as we continue to revalue that if it is
a one-off construction blip and it may
not actually return to below where it
was before covert then we make sure that
we've always got enough depreciation and
would make sure we've rated sufficiently
for our renewals to be able to renew
their assets when they come when they
need to be so we're never going to get
to a stage where we have overvalued and
we end up operating and when we get to
the point of replacement we
find we have done that
I would hope not
so
um just throw yourself to you
um you want to separate the rating
aspect in relation to the valuation it
does give you an indication of what you
should should be rating and we'll we'll
discuss that as part of annual plan
process that is the place where you can
start to reflect in relation to that
potential or life of an asset equation
that you're talking about so it's in the
the rating for the future asset
expenditure that we need to consider as
part of our annual planning process but
the valuation side it is is at my gym
down the end indicated is about the
point in time valuation and that's
what's reflected in the accounts and it
gives you an indication of what you
should be putting aside
for and rating for on a long-term basis
to replace those assets in the longer
term we will discuss it as part of our
annual plan process and in line with our
financial strategy that's cool yeah
thank you are there any other questions
or comments folk would like to make on
the accounts
right can we move to the recommendations
in please but I would like to take a
quite saying issue sorry there's one
thing before we do that I would like to
just focus on
we are making recommendations to Nobby
is Mayor and to our chief executive or
in this case acting dare I say given
where in the slight and oregano if I can
if I can be technical on that
um Michael
um uh that actually two things happen
they sign the statement of compliance
and the annual report
and they sign the letter of
representation
any fake glitter representation let's
see what it is saying well if you want
our opinion on your accounts you own up
to them first
it's a reasonably standard approach and
it's important
that they actually receive that as the
final
point of there are set evidence
or their file to support their opinion
put it the other way
motor no opinion well there will be an
opinion would be different yes sorry
right just a point of clarity around
these letters of representation if you
go to page six
in your board books it's heated order
representation letters and in the second
paragraph
it says these audit representation
letter so it's using a plural then it's
using a singular so are we talking
multiple letters
or singular so there will be a further
letter of representation which you
haven't received yet on the summary
annual report that might just be it
doesn't no English it doesn't quite read
right it's a typo I was hoping we might
have had the little representation for
the summary might have been hopeful
thinking for this meeting so there was
one leader there is one letter you do
also have a back to back letter from
basically initially each of the
representations so that you had that
Assurance no that's cool I just
so there are a couple of things with the
with the letter in on there you've
raised uh your focused focused on it um
bringy that I just want to draw your
attention to
um
essentially we're saying we have
disclosed and made available all
information they need to have to be able
to complete their um the inquiries so
it's important that we have that that's
why it's by the way valuable with our
information back essentially we have uh
what is known as a back-to-back
representation from Patricia is our lead
CFO that actually they have made
available in their opinion all the
information she is giving us some
assurance that we can make a
recommendation to both the mayor and the
chief executive at the literally side
um we do have uh obligations and I'm
looking here particularly at the agenda
pack on page 197 of 251 quite a series
of reasonably important
representatively all important by the
way but I'm just wanting to highlight
two or three that we have disclosed or
known excellent possible litigation
claims I want to reflect that from time
to time Michael you have given us an
update of where you believe all matters
are at we have received it as a
committee and it's important that it's
not only we are that we report on what
we know our liabilities but even also
what our potential contingent
liabilities and we have had that
information at this committee to date
there is at the bottom of page 197 the
important points that Derek has raised
and is asking a specific representation
from Council in relationship to
invercargill Central Limited
which reflects the key transactions
particularly between Council ichl and
ICL
and the nature of that investment in the
value of our loans and our investment
again both Patricia and Derek have
raised those as matters that were part
of the audit and we are needing to and
reasonably so affirm to the Auditors
that we believe
of those loans and the investment are
what we are representing in the annual
report
I think the other thing that is
important I'm now on page 198 because at
another area that is of concern to this
committee is the absence of fraud
or any other matter that would impact on
the reliability of the financial
statements
and so reasonably again we have been
asked to assert
that these accounts are not affected
by Ford
again that's a matter which we we have
talked about at the committee and there
is no indication and we should be
obviously asserting to the auditor that
that is the case
um and also
um the the final point I think that I
would sorry if there's two other points
I'd like to raise the second last one is
that as far as we understand we have
complied with law
there are no matters that we believe we
are materially not complying with the
law
there's a public sector energy that in
itself is reasonable
and the final point which I would have
to raise is on page 199 of the leader of
representation
which is that an important assertion
which can only be formed today
is that invercargill city council is a
going concerned
which is in light of all our
understanding of now our financial
performance
and our position is shown by the balance
sheet
we are in a position going 12 months
forward that we can meet our obligations
when they fall do
you've got that confidence from Patricia
obviously as a committee we need to form
that view and I'm making a broad
assumption that you have I have
that we are going concerned in quite
rightly again we should be asserting
that along with all the representations
to the auditor I just wanted to point
those out to you as we now go to the
recommendations
these comments or questions folk would
like to make before I do that
yes snobby just a couple of things in
relation to 198 that you referred to no
evidence of fraud I guess
um it's not you for any big organization
to assume that there is no fraud you do
that at your peril I guess for us as as
Governors we need to be assured that
um if we do detect fraud in the future
that we have not turned the Blind Eye to
it or that we have methods in place that
would reasonably pick up what would
normally be an appropriate behavior and
so while we're asserting and it's a
position of not knowing what you don't
know it's still a reasonable position to
pay to take so
the other comment I'd make was that you
referred to Michael as an acting chief
executive that's not the case
I have a signed contract with him and
I've publicly announced both internally
and externally that form the 26th of
this month
last month sorry
um the clear has vacated her role
and so Michael is fully appointed
Craig thank you my apologies Michael for
demoting you to acting thank you
correction Bobby yeah thank you no no
offense was intended right um and I'm
sure it's all relatively signed the
right way thank you thank you for that
Lobby
look let's move to the recommendations
and I just want to take it through
carefully because they are important
because it's what I want to stress we
are not making the decision sign we are
recommending to counsel and that's a
decision that you folk will need to talk
about with your colleagues uh this
afternoon and by the way
um Ross will be here physically my plan
is to be able to zoom in from the North
Island
um so we are recommending to council
that we note as a committee
that we've reviewed the draft annual
report we haven't focused on the draft
summary
for reasons that Patricia has outlined
um that has got a bit of work to do and
there's the later delegation sought for
that and we recognize we recommend that
they are both sorry wrecking them both
through adoption
we note that we have reviewed reported
New Zealand's opinion the one that is
published in obviously our agenda
and we have reviewed the letter of
representation which we've just done and
also that we've noted and is included in
your packs the back-to-back letter from
Patricia in effect management
enabling us to have confidence to sign
that letter
um that's number one number two is also
anoking one that the draft order New
Zealand opinion has a limited scope in
relation to the 2021 comparative numbers
so it's important we note that and Tom
thank you for your questions that's got
us to um that's got us to that point
um uh and we note that impact in terms
of the opinion
so we are recommending to council at
three
that they adopt the 2122 annual report
which you have
a chance to review an attachment one
we are authorizing or we are
recommending Council authorizer Social
Security say that Amir and the chief
executive not the acting one what I'm
Michael the chief executive to sign the
letter of representation
and we are recommending to council they
authorize
the mayor and the chief executive
assigned a statement of compliance
which is effectively the annual report
um uh
we are
um recommending
that Patricia have the ability to make
any minor changes but hopefully that
it's publication we don't find too many
spelling mistakes but that's essentially
what we are allowing for there we're
also trying to be efficient with seven
to to pursue the summary
which is yet to be fully completed in
the brief way that has been explained
and we uh I'm effectively asking to
enable me as chair of the risk committee
along with Michael and Patricia to
release that for signing subject to the
receipt of an audit opinion from
New Zealand and
that we authorize the me and the chief
the chief executive and Patricia to sign
the compliance statement
and again
if there are changes of a minor nature
that Patricia is enabled to make those
so it's it's it's an important
substantive decision by this committee
to make those recommendations to uh to
council for this afternoon's business do
I have a mover and a secondary thank you
Ross thank you Leslie
is there any discussion on those
emotions
yes snobby
um so I've got a couple of obligations
under 7B and 7c
to sign as well and I'll be upfront
about that subject to the meeting that
you hold after this meeting with the
audit New Zealand people
and prior to the full council meeting I
will not discharge those issues until
the issue of the performance of audit
New Zealand has resolved
I just want to be upfront about it some
of my colleagues already know I'm going
to take that position
it seems to me it's the only tool that's
available to me at the moment
thank you Bobby you made me aware
yesterday at two o'clock you were at the
view or mine not the sign
um
and
uh certainly appreciate the chance to
talk with you after the meeting yeah I
have and have written you a note with a
strong
recommendation as chair office committee
and I think Ross I can say you support
me in this that we would at urge you not
to follow that strategy we believe that
there is importance in seeing through
this immediate accountability while
indeed we have deep and I can assure you
meaningful discussions with both Stephen
and it was there again over the
performance Award of New Zealand
so thank you for that indication
I think the other comments on the motion
people I can make
you know being none thank you Ross
you've moved Leslie I've got you as the
seconder I'll put those emotions all
those in favor please say aye
aye those against
it's carried
thank you for that
um if I've got it correct we are at the
end of our business Michael I appreciate
you've got a long day and and um Derek
and Stephen thank you for being here
obviously we we have intended and we
will have some discussions we go on I
said I needed to do it twice
but again as as chair of the committee
Patricia thank you to you and indeed
your team for getting us through this
point
um I will reflect that some of the
accounting matters
and I
um are substantial and are significant
in reflect
the nature of the investments in
transactions the council has got got
into I have observed that Patricia is
engaged on those typical issues in a way
that's both professional kindly and
ultimately very helpful to us as a group
of Governors responsible for this
community so Patricia particularly to
you but indeed definitely for your whole
team again can I as chair Express
my thanks I hope in some way that might
even be in the minutes of malavika if we
can do it that way with that thank you
it's a long day can I declare the
meeting close thank you for your being
here tonight